Jeff good morning good morning for
months the pressure had been building on
my cocconi with and he was telling
reporters that he expected to be charged
in the end he gave up and surrendered to
prosecutors Cohen once bragged that he
would take a bullet for president Trump
but yesterday he took a plea deal from
prosecutors instead Michael Cohen left
the US District Court in Manhattan after
admitting to tax evasion and campaign
finance violations Cohen's voice cracked
in court as he answered the judges
questions and admitted that mr. Trump
directed him to make hush money payments
to adult film star stormy Daniels and
Playboy model Karen McDougal
Cohen said the payments were made in
coordination and at the direction of the
same candidate and that it was done to
keep the women from disclosing
information for the principle purpose of
influencing the election
[Music]
well you have to ask Michael Kohn
Michael's my an attorney after first
denying he knew about Cohen's payment to
Daniel's a month later the president
acknowledged he repaid Cowan through a
monthly retainer to stop the false and
extortionist accusations made by her
about an affair these are very serious
charges and reflect a pattern of Lies
and dishonesty deputy US attorney Robert
Kazami said Cowan decided he was above
the law and for that he was going to pay
a very very serious price for more than
a decade Cohen was mr. Trump's so-called
fixer but in recent months after
investigators raided his office home in
hotel room he became alienated from
President Trump and increasingly
signaled a willingness to turn on him
just last month he and his attorney
released recordings Cohen had made a
president trunk two months before the
election allegedly discussing the
payment to mcdougal the president's
attorney Rudy Giuliani said quote there
is no allegation of any wrongdoing
against the president in the
government's charges but prosecutors say
the Trump Organization repaid Cohen for
the 280,000 dollars that was used to pay
the two women